well I would add one thing I would say
like if you are dating someone
monogamously to discern marriage and
they can't be monogamous through the
courtship process that does tell you
something about them it's like all right
yeah you're not the one for me yeah but
I mean from from your standard Sheamus
they're like the person you're dating is
not going around having sex with a bunch
of dudes no it's also true yes so
there's not at least if she does I don't
know about it but what are you saying
like if you're if you would never date a
woman like that so
is like you're going out for dinner and
you're going to the movies and then one
day you find out she went out to a movie
with Ian and I would be I would be like
your first movie ever happened they're
going to see what is a woman and I'm
like apparently a liar and a cheater I
could tell Matt Walsh what a woman is if